rusia despidió a mijail gorbachov en
moscú el último líder de la unión
soviética murió el pasado martes a los
91 años y fue enterrado este sábado sin
honras de estado ni la presencia del
presidente vladimir putin su cuerpo fue
velado en el icónico salón de las
columnas de moscú
la unión europea' se declara preparada
para afrontar el desabastecimiento de
gas ruso así lo anunció el comisario
europeo de economía paolo gentiloni
después de que la empresa estatal rusa
gazprom
informará del corte total e indefinido
del suministro a través del gaseoducto
no estimuló
cancelado por segunda vez el lanzamiento
de artemis uno de la nasa la agencia
espacial estadounidense argumentó una
nueva fuga de hidrógeno en el cohete
como motivo de la suspensión de la
misión que pretende que la humanidad
regrese a la luna
buenas tardes bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24
soy rosa pérez masdéu y es para mí un
gusto acompañarles
empezamos en rusia porque mijail
gorbachov el último líder de la unión
soviética fallecido el martes fue
despedido por familiares y ciudadanos en
el mismo cementerio donde reposa el
cuerpo de su esposa en moscú aunque el
kremlin no le otorgó el honor de
dedicarle un funeral de estado y el
presidente putin no acudió al entierro
el gobierno ruso sí que le concedió el
reconocimiento de ser velado en el
mítico salón de las columnas velatorio
de otros líderes soviéticos el informe
es de alva santana
último adiós de rusia mijaíl gorbachov
rodeado de sus seres queridos y de miles
de seguidores el último líder de la
antigua unión soviética fue enterrado en
moscú tras morir a los 91 años
[Música]
creo que esta persona se merecía una
ceremonia de despedida verdaderamente
popular es una persona histórica
independientemente de lo que piense en
algunos hizo mucho aunque algunos
piensan que hizo más mal que bien yo
creo que hizo más bien
y es que el político reformista lidera
el final de la guerra fría y marcó la
apertura de rusia al mundo en los 90 en
lo que finalmente acabó con la unión
soviética fue enterrado sin la
característica ceremonia de estado de
sus predecesores y sin retransmisión en
directo de la televisión estatal además
de contar con una gran ausencia la del
presidente vladimir putin que se limitó
a llevarle un ramo de rosas tras
conocerse su muerte el martes
debemos apreciar las cosas buenas que
gorbachov hizo por nosotros contribuyó
mucho al desarrollo de los medios de
comunicación de la sociedad civil y en
general apoyo a nuestro país en el
ámbito internacional
9 con claveles y rosas rojas cientos de
rusos hicieron fila frente a la famosa
casa de los sindicatos de moscú donde se
celebró la ceremonia de despedida de
gorbachov quien con su vida remarca el
fin de una era en rusia ahora en medio
de una nueva guerra
y precisamente tras la muerte del ex
líder soviético mijail gorbachov
vladimir putin no tardó en expresar sus
profundas condolencias a través de un
lacónico comunicado del kremlin pero sin
el clásico telegrama a la familia y
allegados una acción que muestra la
ambigua relación entre los dos
dirigentes
la imagen ha provocado especulaciones en
la última década en mayo de 2012 cuando
vladimir putin fue investido presidente
por tercera vez mijail gorbachov asistió
a la ceremonia está firmado pero nadie
sabe lo que dijo a partir de ese momento
se volvió muy crítico con el presidente
ruso y sostuvo que tres mandatos
presidenciales son demasiados
un año después habló públicamente del
tema en una gala en su honor en eeuu y
luego en un programa de radio
no aconsejaría a vladimir putin que se
fuera ya ha tenido tres mandatos dos
como presidente y uno como primer
ministro tres mandatos son suficientes
se están creando planes a su alrededor
vladimir putin habló de la caída de la
urss como una gran catástrofe del siglo
20 con una crítica velada a su último
líder no obstante mijail gorbachov apoyó
a vladimir putin durante sus primeros
años en el poder e incluso le aconsejó
apoyó sus esfuerzos para que nuestro
estado sea más eficiente con el fin de
establecer orden en el país cosas que se
pueden cuestionar pero creo que su rumbo
es el correcto en realidad la relación
entre los dos hombres fue ambigua
los dos hombres coinciden es en la
necesidad de ampliar la influencia
internacional que le pertenece a rusia
legítimamente en lo que son radicalmente
diferentes es en que putin no es
comunista bajo ningún precepto mientras
que mijail gorbachov era un comunista
convencido ministro
gorbachov no llego a decir mucho sobre
la guerra en ucrania su fundación emitió
una declaración dos días después del
inicio de la invasión rusa en la que
pedía el fin de los combates y el inicio
inmediato de las negociaciones de paz no
obstante unos años antes gorbachov apoyó
la invasión rusa de crimea
y la central nuclear de sabor y allá fue
desconectada de nuevo de la red
eléctrica ucraniana según informó el
organismo internacional de la energía
atómica pero la central continúa
suministrando energía a través de una
línea de reserva
recordemos que dos funcionarios del
organismo permanecen en la planta en el
marco de una misión de control para
evitar un desastre nuclear fruto de los
combates en la zona de hecho el
ministerio de defensa de rusia anunció
este sábado que frenó un ataque
ucraniano que intentaba retomar el
control de la planta según el ejército
ruso tropas ucranianas llegaron en
helicópteros y buques a un lago cercano
a la central las fuerzas rusas aseguran
haber matado a 47 militares de que el
mismo dron apresurado a pesar de la
presencia de representantes de loja en
la central nuclear de safari ya el
régimen de kiev intentó una vez más
apoderarse de la central el 2 de
septiembre alrededor de las 23 horas de
moscú los grupos de un total de 42
embarcaciones con más de 250.000 de las
fuerzas de operaciones especiales y
mercenarios extranjeros a bordo
intentaron desembarcar en la orilla del
embalse de kafka cerca de enero dar
rayones en la caldera línea producto
la empresa alemana siemens desmintió el
discurso de la empresa estatal rusa
gazprom sobre la suspensión del flujo de
gas a europa a través del gasoducto nord
stream 1 gazprom asegura que una fuga de
aceite detectada en una turbina durante
tareas de mantenimiento impide la
entrega de gas
sin embargo siemens asegura que
incidencias de este tipo en el pasado no
conllevaron el cese de la actividad por
otro lado recordemos que la presidenta
de la comisión europea úrsula von der
leyen declaró esta semana la intención
de bruselas de intervenir el mercado
energético europeo y este sábado el
comisario europeo de economía paolo
gentiloni aseguró que la unión europea
está preparada para la interrupción del
gas ruso putin para un paso putin dando
un paso más hacia el corte de los
suministros una violación de contrato
sería una violación de los contratos
todos esperan que eso no suceda si
sucede es claro que habrá consecuencias
pero también es claro que nos hemos
estado preparando durante meses para
este riesgo por lo que no debemos
subestimar
pronto veamos pero ciertamente no nos
dejaremos intimidar que farc sin timidez
en pakistán las inundaciones afectan a
un tercio del territorio ya 33 millones
de personas lo que representa el 15 por
ciento de la población del país en su
último informe las autoridades de
islamabad reportaron 57 muertes más lo
que aumenta el total de fallecidos a
1.265 desde que comenzaron las lluvias
monzónicas de mediados de junio los
detalles con laurel como este pueblo
muchos se convirtieron en ríos en
pakistán las inundaciones sin presentes
siguen forzando a miles de personas a
huir de sus casas y enfrentarse a
instalaciones deplorables en condiciones
de hacinamiento hacia el área nos
salvamos de morir ahogados en las
inundaciones pero nuestra casa se
derrumbó escapamos pero no pudimos
salvar nuestros bienes de alcohol alga
tengamos aquí en un estado terrible
algunas buenas personas de aquí nos
dieron refugio ahora estamos recibiendo
algo de ayuda
pero solo suficiente para llenar
nuestros estómagos y ahora es la
organización de naciones unidas alerta
que estas condiciones precarias ponen
especialmente en riesgo la vida de los
niños por la propagación de enfermedades
transmitidas a través del agua de las
1200 personas que fallecieron más de 400
eran menores el sábado el gobierno
paquistaní advirtió nuevamente la
urgencia de la situación es que el off
de base station es va a ser la escala de
la devastación es masiva y requiere una
inmensa respuesta humanitaria para 33
millones de personas trivelli en vivo
por ello hago un llamamiento a mis
compatriotas a los paquistaníes
expatriados y a la comunidad
internacional para que ayuden a pakistán
en esta hora de necesidad
funcionarios y expertos achacan el nivel
inusual de lluvias monzónicas en
pakistán al cambio climático entre ellos
el secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres que instó al mundo a dejar de
caminar durmiendo en esta crisis
guterres recorrerá las zonas afectadas
por las inundaciones en pakistán
9 de septiembre
y venimos a nuestra región porque mañana
domingo chile votará en el plebiscito
sobre la propuesta de la nueva
constitución 15 millones de ciudadanos
están llamados a elegir entre el apruebo
o el rechazo del texto elaborado durante
un año por la asamblea constitucional
conformada de forma paritaria y con
escaños reservados a los pueblos
originarios el oficialismo defiende el
apruebo y si el borrador es rechazado
promoverá la elección de una nueva
asamblea que prepare una nueva propuesta
recordemos que en 2020 el 80% de los
chilenos votaron a favor de redactar una
nueva carta magna tras las masivas
protestas de 2019 contra el sistema
político y económico heredado de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet sin
embargo las últimas encuestas publicadas
hace más de 15 días daban una ventaja de
cerca de 10 puntos a la opción del
rechazo a la nueva constitución que
establece un estado social de derecho
plurinacional
estamos muy contento muy esperanzado de
que nuevamente país donde hay
diferencias pongamos más democracia y
creemos que el gran ganador del día
domingo va a ser sin duda la democracia
y están todas las condiciones dadas para
que en nuestra región sea un proceso
tranquilo y seguro que íbamos a florida
la nasa suspendió por segunda vez el
lanzamiento de la misión artemis uno por
una fuga en el conducto de combustible
del cohete se retrasa de nuevo este paso
previo al regreso de la humanidad la
luna luego de 50 años estas son las
explicaciones de la nasa escuchemos
bueno el equipo de gestión de la misión
se reunirá esta tarde van a analizar lo
van a ver si todavía existe una
posibilidad ahora o van a tener que
regresar al edificio de ensamblaje de
vehículos si se decide que ese es el
caso entonces el lanzamiento será en
octubre diría que en octubre aunque la
ventana se abre temprano entonces
sospecho que será más bien a mediados
porque recuerden la primera semana de
octubre tenemos otro equipo es una
tripulación internacional dos
participantes internacionales en la
tripulación de cuatro que van a la
estación espacial internacional
[Música]
la tenista estadounidense serena
williams perdió el viernes ante la
australiana ángela tomljanovic en nueva
york' en el land en el que anunció sería
el último partido de su carrera william
se despidió del torneo y uss open entre
múltiples mensajes de admiración a
semanas de cumplir 41 años el retiro de
williams insinuado por ella misma en la
revista vogue hace semanas parece
inminente para analizar la estelar
trayectoria de la deportista conversamos
con la ex tenista colombiana mariana
mesa y esto nos dijo
pues estaba una expectativa yo creo que
ayer los gestos
de emoción todo el público
ovacionando la no sólo los que
estuvieron presentes en la cancha sino
en el mundo
el seguimiento digamos de este partido
que fue espectacular yo creería que si
ya definitivamente se va a retirar y se
retira con la puerta grande muchos
depronto piensan que porque perdió en
tres en tercera ronda de pronto no salió
por la puerta grande pero 23 grand slam
yo creo que son suficientes para hacer
la mejor tenista de la historia no sólo
en el ámbito femenino sino también en el
masculino sólo se habla de los hombres
pero para mí es la mejor tenista de la
historia porque guau guau qué logros y
qué mujer de verdad que también ha
apoyado mucho la equidad de género en el
deporte y en el tenis femenino son 23
grandes lado los que ganó serena
williams le sigue rafael nadal con 22
después djokovic con 21 y federer con 20
eso demuestra que ha sido la tenista más
grande de la historia en el ámbito
femenino masculino y se va a una de las
grandes y yo creo que voy a dejar un
hueco muy importante en el deporte en el
deporte femenino porque lo que jalaba en
términos de audiencia de patrocinios es
muy importante y creo que en el tenis se
va a demorar mucho tiempo y sobre todo
el tenis
de esa magnitud
y nos despedimos con deportes porque el
ecuatoriano richard carpas ganó la
decimocuarta etapa de la vuelta españa
disputada en andalucía en el sur del
país cara paz se situó a la cabeza tras
adelantar al belga even o paul quien
lideró gran parte de los 160 kilómetros
de carrera
muchísimas gracias por su atención
sigan con nosotros entran 34 y france24
puntocom
[Música]